Bob: I'm excited. ARE YOU EXCITED?
Mark: *laughs*
Wade: Yeah Bob owo
B: just lets have a GOOD TIME
M: Frames FRAMES Frames Frames
M: FRAMES
M: FRames
M: FRAAAAAAAAAAAAAMES
M: Aw no way
B: Hilarious
Automated Mark: Aw no way
Automated Mark: Aww me too man
Automated Mark: Yes I agree
Bob&Wade: *Dying*
M: *giggleplier*
B: Yes yes
Ethan: I'm going to go
M: Tha- *dies with laughter*
Wade&Bob: *also laughing*
M: FRAMES frames FRAAAMES frAAAAAAAMES.
M: Okay, we're back.
M: FRAME–
W: I feel like this is all just Mark recording.
Automated Mark: You Right.
Actual Mark: *agrees with his automated self*
Bob&Wade: *starts laughing*
M:I-It's like you hate me, it's like ya' hate me.
B: [laughs in background]
M: I don't get it.
W: It says thank you or fuck you.
W: I'm trying to help you figure out which one.
M: You tryna to thank fuck me. I don't think that's a FUCK style.
B: [dying of laughter]
W: Oh fuck you thank you.
M: Thank fuck you.
M: THANK FuCK mE AND FUCK THANK YoU.
B: Aw thanks, fuck you.
W: *singing* It's the thank fuck-iest time....
M: Look it's gotta be a PG thank fucking stream.
W: Oh WHOO-OO--*coughs violently*.
Mark and Bob: [laughs]
B: How do we restart th- how do we play
W: I do it.
B: Okay.
M: oH, WaDe DoeS iT
oh OkAy.
W: Well I hosted the server.
W: What do you think?
M: oH WAdE DoeS IT.
M: Oh OKAY.
B: Mark? Mark?
M: Yees?
B: Don't walk like that, it's terrifying.
M: (bad accent) What's wrong? You afraid of my FleXiBiLiTY?
M: (accent) I'm ready.
M: (accent) Okay, goodbye.
M: (Questionable accent) Wade, WADE.
M:  (Questionable accent) I'M READY FOR YOU.
M: (Questionable accent) WADE GET OVER HERE AND FuCK ME.
W: Oh fuck.?
B: You right.
M: [giggles]
W: Alright.
Automated M: You right.
M: [giggles]
W: Stop.
B: Goddammit.
Automated M: Uh huh.
W: Is that really mark?
B: No it's not.
Automated M: Yes!
M:...and then I'mma do this move.
W: Oh, I was gonna go here, you asshole.
B: Oh you unbelievable, cUCk monster.
M: W-What did I do? You- I- Was trying to- [stutters]
W: You fucking dick!
M: WHAT DID I DO?
W&B&E: [booing sounds]
M: I don't deserve this hate!
W&B&E: [continous booing sounds]
M: I don't deserve this!
E: Wade...Wade would do great in medieval times.
*M&B laughing*
He would be such a great peasant.
*M&B still laughing*
M: By the way, I know you guys were concerned but the frames are...bAD BAD.
M: Frames fra-FRAMES. WHY? WH- THIS IS NOT FAIR.
W: Ah, hearts-
M: Hearts of my cards
B: Oh... Oh, no
W: Oh
M: Watch this, I'm- I'm immune!
M: Aw
W: Ok alright that's a pretty even distribut-
M: OW
W: Alright, I'll take it
[Mark groaning]
B: [mockingly] I'm immune.
B: [mockingly] Watch me, I'm immune.
B: I think I'm getting my GODDAMN SPOT BACK!
W: No!
B: Get off me!
B: *Struggles*
M+W: *laughter*
W: *laughter*
B:..you can't hurt me but I'm just saying we're b-buddies, right, we're buddies, it's okay.
M: I'm seeing blood. *chuckles*
W: *laughing*
B: w-wait on who?
B: on who??
M: My eyes are shooting blood out of 'em.
W: [in shock and confusion]
B: EAT
B: A
B: GIANT
B: PILE
B: OF SHHUT THE FUCK UP!
M: *laughing*
W: *sputtering, laughing*
B: But am I right though?
Automated M: You right.
W: agh- *unintelligible* stop
W: GRAPES?
M: Get anything going on here
M: OH x10
M: Okay, alright! x2 Okay.
B: *distressed* You guys playing UNO over there?
B: *distressed* what are you guys doing over there? Is it uno?
W: We're good, Bob! Watcha talkin?
B: *distressed* Looks like fun!...
B: *distressed* I was gonna play some of that too...
M: Ow...Fuck! Why?
M: Wha- ew
B: *normal* 'Cause fuck you, thanks
M: Aw, right?
M: Has everybody watching followed Bob and Wade on their Twitch channels yet?
B: 'Cause if you haven't, FUck YOU!!
W: Yeah!!
M: *Laughing* This is the slowest game we've ever played.
W: Well, we're teaching Ethan how to play
M: HE'S PLAYED BEFORE!!!
W: ... Oh and a very good +4, now s–
M: Now, you right!
M: Yeah, you right. You right
W: Shit I didn't get to jump in 'cause fuck everything!
B: Now I don't know if it's really you or the recording, that's terrifying!
W: You right.
M: You right.
AM: You right M: You right.  x2
*bob laughs*
M: God I can't-Oh the one time my lid is open, I can't grab a fucking grenade before you asshole
M: GOD THERE GOES MY FRAMES.
B: Oh ho ho ho ho no ho ho!
B: He's got two in the home!
B: 1,2,3,4,5,6
W: Oh yeah he does.
M: What I'm gonna do
M: What I'm  (going to) do
B: No, Mark.
M: is I'm gonna get this guy-Imma get this guy out
B:Mark!
M: because I'm gonna use my other role to get away from that.
B: No!
B: So you're teaming with Wade now?!
M: No!
M: I'm being...
M: OHWOAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAH W: *rages*
B: *distressed* You guys playin' Uno?
M+W: *laughs*
B: *distressed* You having fun?
M: It was for our benefit, good dick. I love good dick.
E: Does Mark 2702 work on postmates?
M: Yes.
M: No, oh YOU lost YOUR pole. Oh, we have to restart it because YOU lose your pole?
W: Uh yeah, the boat ate my pole, I didn't just drop it, the boat ate it.
M: NO I-
B: I think outta fairness, Mark, I think we should restart
M: I DIDN'T DROP MY PO-
*Solid Snake ! sound*
B+W: *laugh*
M: Here comes the Sorry, baby!
M: AHH!!
W: WHAT A PLAY!!
M: SHIT!!
M: YES!!
B: What a play!
M: YES!
W: What a save!
*stock applause plays, triumphant music*
M: YES!!
B: Oh baby, a triple
x2
B: Alright, here comes my reverse Sorry.
B: Huah, YES!
M: NO!
*fortnite down sound*
B: Wait why? Why would you do this? Idon'twannadothis.
W: Oh, oH! I love you computer!
M: [in shock and confusion]
B: Oh shit.
W: [screaming] OH NO!
W: [screaming] NO!
M: [laughing]
M: I understand you.
M: I see you.
M: Wade,y-your advice is not really that good.
W: Are you sure?
M: yEeaAh!
E: Can I...
W: No.
M: No one takes longer to take their turn than you, Ethan!
M: No one!
M: Frames?
M: Is that a fr-yeah.
M: Is that a fr-yeah
B: Noooo
B: GOD
B: DAMN
B: YOU
M: Okay, that's the last frames.
W: Oh okay, you get to c– five times in a row.
B: God fucking–
B: I hate you, frames. Frames
B: Frames!
B: If Mark gets frames I get frames!
B: No!
B: Everyone, shut up!
B: I'm thinking!
M: No!
W: I-Is this frames?
M: No.
B: NO DON'T YOU FUCKING DARE.
W: [unintelligible shouting in anger]
W: MAKE IT YELLOW!
W: YOU FUCKING CUTIE ASSHOLE!
W: BITCH!
B: Thank you so much, I'd like to thank all my fans you really brought me here. I would like to thank everyone for supporting me all these years
B: Finally got a click on a fucking card.
M: [Laughs]
M: Crippling debt? There's an app for that!
M: Cockfights? There's an app for that!
M: Poor people! [Laughs]
M: I'm gonna go with the poor people.
M: Oh no!
B: Fucking...random douchebag!
B: God dammit!
W: I get all these shitty cards.
W: Yeah I know.
M: [laughs]
B: I wish I had poor people!
B: I wish I had poor people
M+W: [laughs]
M: My controller is still on and it's just vibrating
M: I'm just gonna put this in
M: My lap for no reason alright
W: Mark owns a lot of expensive property.
M: Yeah, I do. Yeah, I do baby I do
B: You right
M: Holy shit
AM: You right
B: Holy shit
M: I like having my own little crew here
M: [chuckles]
B: [laughing]
W: Your own group of you's?
M: Yeah
B: Mark's back-up 'yes men'
M: [laughs]
M: I just keep laughing b'cus you guys makes life so fun,
E: all right, I think my life is over
M: Wha- ha haha
M+W+B: [laughter]
M: Anybody want brick I've got a shitload. I've got a
E: I would like brick.
M: What do you want for it?
E: I want brick
ALL: [laughter]
M: The door swings open she walks in legs up to here something in her eyes tells me she's looking for...
M: [laughing] fuck mountain! [laughing]
M+W+B: [laughter]
B: Mark, how much heart of the cards do you have
M: Not very much
B: Alright, I'm not gonna do it then
M: [chuckles]
W: Why? Why'd you wanna punish poor ol' wadey?
B: Why why would we want to punish you? Why punish you?
W: I deserve a win, it's been a long day
B: Y O U  A L R E A D Y
W O N
M: [laughter]
W: I can't wait to see how this ends–
M: dude, you– you you know me
M: and I know you, and we know each other
M: and you know how this is gonna end
B: You done?
B: Whoa, whoa, whoa, you don't like the utilities
M: Wade, do nOT
W: YOU'RE GETTIng two monopolies by the way
M: be fooled you are getting
M: FOOLED
W: I'm getting no monopolies out of this, Bob
M: Exactly. 4 for 2, wouldn't be fair for YOU in this exchange.
M: He would have to give you ALL of his money for that to happen!
B: Mark is overselling it because he's dramatic
M: WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?!?
W: That is my offer
M: [freaking out]
B: Yeah, well obviously Im going to take that.
M: YOU ARE A FUCKING IDIOT!!!
B: Alright let's
W: You are jumping
B: Oh, buddy that's just– that's unnecessary
W: Was gonna–
M: I am the funniest
M: man on the face of the earth
W: What will always get you laid? My sex dungeon
W: So, um
M: [baffled] What?
M: What?
W: there's a big inside joke with Agent
B: Did you just say Asian?
B: Oh, okay. Agent.
W: Agent
M: I-I literally thought you were like, "Asian, that's for you. You know who you are."
W: No! Agent! Not Asian.
B: I know how you love your sex dungeons, in Asia. Asians, that one's for you.
M: Wade, can you make it?
M: We believe in-
W: [screams] Come on! Bob!
B: Just do it Wade, it's fine I definitely won't kill you again.
W: Okay. All right. I'm gonna believe you. I choose to believe you.
M: Mmhmm, mmhmm
W: No one's landed on my fucking, house.
B: Giggity, giggity go car.
W: All right, nevermind. Go see Mark.
M: YEAAAAAAAAH!
B: Ooo, I got the bad one.
W: Holy shit!
B: Ohhh noooo.
W: Mark, I told ya! You win on this deal! You win on this deal! You win!
AM: You right! You right!
M: You right, you right!
W: You win!
AM: YoU riGHt! yOU rIGhT! You right!
W: Buy that fourth house!
AM: YoU RiGHt
AM: yOu rIGht
W: Thank you. Loving you is easy cuz you're...socks. What?
M+B+W: [laughter]
W: Oh yeah? Well.
B: Okay.
M: *laughs*
M: It's about to go down. I've got...
M: Uh, 1 2 3 4.
E: That's what you said last time.
M: I-It is going down-no, that's a road. It is going down this time! 1 2 3 4. Right? 4 stone.
M: BAM! Put those in there. I get two wheat back. Oh, but wait, they're not staying there long,
M: cuz here's-here's these, then there's this one, and this is for a city, going in here.
M: Let's slap down here, and badabing-badaboom
But wait! That's it.
W+B+E: [laughter]
W: Nicely done, man. Nicely done.
E: Okay. Okay.
M: Uh, thank you.
M: I gOTta dRaW AGaIn
B+W: [laughter]
M: NooOoOoooOOo
M: NooOOOoOoOOoo
B+W: *still laughing*
M: NOOOoOOoo *starts laughing*
M: Nooo... Heart of my cards!
B: I have a gift for you, Mark.
M: Yeah? Okay.
W: NOOOOOOOOO
M: Oh...You right, you right, you right, you-
AM: YoU rIgHT
B: Sto- *laughs*
[Outro Music]